[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار السهل بابرز
العناو
بعد زياره اليكو هان الى الخرطوم السودان
يعلن الاتفاق مع اسرائيل على تطبيع
العلاقات والتعاون امنيا وعسكريا
بامجاد انتصارات ستالينغراد بوتين يتوعد
بمحو دبابات الالمانيه من على حدوده
[موسيقى]
في كافه المجالات
في داخل البلد
الشرفاء يتعاونون معنا
المؤسسه العسكريه في ايران
قصه وقضيه انهيار مجموعه اداني تتفاعل
والمخاوف تلاحق المستثمرين فيها
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الخرطوم حيث اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه الاتفاق مع
اسرائيل على المضي قدما في تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين وقال بيان الوزاره ان وزير
الخارجيه علي الصادق التقى نظيره
الاسرائيلي حيث تم الاتفاق على تطوير
علاقات البلدين في مجالات الزراعه والطاقه
والصحه والمياه والتعليم واضافت الخارجيه
السودانيه انه تم حذف اسرائيل على العمل
على تحقيق الاستقرار والسلام للشعب
الفلسطيني
قبل ذلك قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
ان رئيس المجلس عبد الفتاح البرهان التقى
في الخرطوم وفدا اسرائيليا برئاسه وزير
الخارجيه اليكوهان وافاد البيان ان اللقاء
تطرق الى سبل ارساء علاقات وصفها بالمثمره
مع اسرائيل وكذلك تعزيز افاق التعاون
المشترك في مجالات مختلفه من بينها
الامنيه والعسكريه واشار الاتفاق والبيان
بيان المجلس السيادي الى ان الجانب
السوداني حتى اسرائيل على تحقيق الاستقرار
بين اسرائيل والشعب الفلسطيني
ينضم الينا من القدس لنيسان المحلل
السياسي استاذ ايلي يعني السياسه الواقعيه
التي انتهجتها السودان بموضوع انضمام الى
اتفاقيات ابرهم بتطبيع العلاقات مع
اسرائيل الى اي مدى اليوم هو من مصلحه
السودان ومن مصلحه الجانب الاسرائيلي
اولا هذه الزياره تندرج في
اضافه الى ما قام به رئيس الوزراء ورئيس
تشاد اليوم بافتتاح
السفاره الارشاديه في اورشليم القدس وهذا
يعني بمعنى ان اسرائيل لها موضع قدم في
افريقيا
والتطورات كبيره في المستقبل في القاره
السوداء طبعا هذه اول زياره
على الملا التي يقوم بها وزير
الخارجيهين
واعتقد ان هذه الزياره تخدم مصلحه
الدولتين اولا كما عرف ان تم التوقيع على
ضم اسرائيل
الى مجلس البحر الاحمر
وهذا المجلس يدوم ايضا السعوديه ويضم ايضا
مصر واسرائيل طبعا السودان اسرائيل تكون
عضو في هذا المجلس من الناحيه الامنيه
اسرائيل لها استطاعه ان تقدم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
والاستراتيجيه
للسودان مع العلم ان السودان كانت في
الماضي من اكبر الاعداء لدوله اسرائيل
وقامت حسب المعلومات التي نشرت تعييرات
اسرائيليه باستهداف مواقع داخل السودان
ولكن اليوم تغيرت الاوضاع
من المعلوم ان هناك علاقه جيده بين
القيادات العسكريه والسياسيه الاسرائيليه
والقيادات العسكريه السودانيه واليوم
الخيارات الاقليميه والدوليه للسودان
اختلفت عن المرحله الماضيه في عام 2020
اعلنت
الانضمام الى هذا الاتفاق فورميلات واليوم
عادت من جديد ما الذي تغير وما الذي
سيتحقق من هذا الاتفاق الان
تعلمين ان كانوا في الماضي
بعض الجهات داخل السودان جهاد اسلاميه
التي عارضت التوقيع او تطبيق العلاقات بين
اسرائيل وبين السودان اليوم بعد اعاده
الهدوء في شوارع شوارع السودان اعتقد ان
سودان سيكون الدوله القادمه التي تقوم
بتطبيع العلاقات بين اسرائيل وبين السودان
ويتم هذا الموضوع اضافه له افتتاح سفرات
خلال الاسابيع القليله القادمه بين
اسرائيل وبين السودان وكما قلت ان اسرائيل
لها امكانيات
لم تقديم المساعدات الايران في شتى
المجالات من بينها كما ذكرت مجالات امنيه
وعسكريه وايضا استثمارات تجاريه داخل
السودان وطبعا امور اقتصاديه
من المعلوم هناك بند اساسي ايضا بكل هذه
الاتفاقيات هو الوضع الاقتصادي المساعدات
العسكريه
الاقتصاديه التي قدم الجانب الامريكي
ويقدم ايضا الجانب الاسرائيلي هل هذه
الاتفاقيه تضمن الجانب الامني والقومي
للسوداني اليوم كما تضمن مصالح اسرائيل
باختصار لو سمحت عندما عندما انضمت
2021 السودان الى الاتفاقيات اتفاقيات
ابراهيم مع العلم انه لم يكن حتى هذه
الفتره تطبيق العلاقات بين اسرائيل وبين
السودان وانما هذا الامر هو في في مراحل
قريبه جدا
هناك ايضا مصالح امريكيه طبعا هذا الامر
كان بوساطه امريكيه والولايات المتحده
والولايات المتحده
وعدت اولا بازاله السودان
دوله دوله تدعم الارهاب وثانيا الولايات
المتحده تقدم المساعده الاقتصاديه
والماليه واستثمارات امريكيه اذا الجانب
الاستثمارات الاسرائيليه في السودان اعتقد
ان كل هذه الامور وطبعا الامور الزراعيه
لان اسرائيل لها خبرات كبيره في مجال الري
والتصحر وهناك امكانيه
للتعاون في كافه المجالات اسرائيل ولكن
طبعا المصالح الاسرائيليه تتخطى موضوع
الري والتصحر هناك مصالح استراتيجيه اكبر
بكثير من هذا الموضوع شكرا لك استاذ دائري
نيسان المحلل السياسي حدثنا من القدس
اهلا وسهلا
قال الرئيس بوتين خلال كلمته بمناسبه
الذكرى الثمانين لمعركه ستالينغراد ان
الغرب يريد القتال في اوكرانيا بايادي
هتلر عبر ارسال دبابات الالمانيه محددا
بالرد على ارسال الدبابات
للاسف نرى ايدولوجيه النازيه عادت لتشكل
خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا ونحن مضطرون من
جديد ان نجابه عدوان الغرب الذين يهددوننا
بدبابات الالمانيه ويريدون الان ان
يحاربوا في اوكرانيا على ايدي خلفائه هتلر
هذا واعتبر نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري ان واجب موسكو عدم اعطاء مواصفها
بالنازيه الجديده فرصه للانتقام مما حدث
قبل 80 عاما في تصريح المسؤول الرسلجا على
حسابه في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في ذكرى
80 للانتصار في معركه ستالينغراد واضافات
ان روسيا كسرت العدو حينها متواعدا بمنعه
من الانتصار في الوقت الراهن يذكر ان
معركه ستالينغلاد التي استمرت من يوليو
عام 1942 حتى الثاني من فبراير عام 1943
غيرت مسار الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والى جانب تهديدات بوتين قال المتحدث باسم
كريم ان روسيا ستستخدم قوتها العسكريه
بشكل كامل واضف بسكوب انه ردا على الدعم
العسكري الغربي المتزايد لاوكرانيا فان
روسيا لا تجد بديلا عن الاستفاده بشكل
كامل من امكاناتها العسكريه
صباح وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان الغرب يتطلع
لتكون مولدوفا اوكرانيا التاليه كما اشار
لافرو في مقابله مع قناه روسيا 24 الى ان
الغرب يريد تحويل جورجيا الى مصدر ازعاج
اخر لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ناقشنا عقوبه جديده ضد روسيا الحزمه
العاشره من عقوبه الاتحاد الاوروبي على
وجه الخصوص المهمه المشتركه للاتحاد
الاوروبي هي تقليل قدره روسيا على تجاوز
العقوبات وكلما تم تحقيق ذلك في وقت مبكر
اقتربنا من هزيمه العدوان الروسي لاحظنا
ان وتيره العقوبات قد طابات قليلا بينما
سارعت روسيا بالتكيف علينا اصلاح ذلك
اعتقد انه بامكاننا القيام بالامر
سبق كل هذا التراشق السياسي نشر موسكو
صواريخ يارس الاستراتيجيه ووضعها في حاله
الجاهزيه القتاليه
صواريخ ار اس 22
الف كيلو متر
قادره على حمل اربعه رؤوس قتاليه
الخطا لا تتعدى 120 متر قادره على تغيير
المواقع والتمويه
كذلك المناوره وتجاوز الطلوع الصاروخيه
ينضم الينا من موسكو
المحلل السياسي
اذا تحدثنا عن يعني عن المعنويه الرمزيه
لمعركه ستالينغراد بالامس بعد هذه المعركه
هناك عديد من الدول منها اليابان وتركيا
اضطرت يومها يعني الوقوف الى جانب الاتحاد
السوفياتي والاعتراف بدفاعها عن الاراضي
الولايات المتحده عدلت موقفها بوجه
النازيه اليوم الموقف مغير تماما ما الذي
يريد ان يقوله بوتين بهذه الذكرى
تحياتي لك ولساده البوشنية الذي يريد ان
يقوله بوتين اليوم ان روسيا التي كانت قد
لعبت دورا في دحر الناجي منذ 80 سنه
تقريبا لا تزال الان تقوم بنفس المهمه فهو
يعتقد بان النظام الاوكراني الحاكم هو
نظام ناجي اي نظام غرق في
الجيولوجيا النازيه ويستخدم نفس الاساليب
التي استخدمتها المانيا الناجيه منذ 80
سنه طبعا يعني اتحدث عن العالم الغربي يقف
ضد خيار موسكو لانه يعتبر ان هذه الحرب
كانت عبثيه تهديد روسيا اليوم بتدمير كل
الاسلحه الغربيه ومنها الدبابات التي
ستسلم لاوكرانيا كيف يمكن يعني تصريفها
على الارض بالمعنى الواقعي
تهديد هذه انواع الجديده من الدبابات لا
يعني برايي انا ان روسيا سوف تلجا الى
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه كما يعتقد
الكثيرين في الغرب وهم بتابعيه الخال
يخشون من مثل هذا السيناريو ومن مثل هذا
التحول المحتمل ولكن روسيا افهمت اليوم
وعلى لسان الناطق باسم
بان ما قاله الرئيس بوتين تقريبا يعني لا
اتذكر هذه الفقره بدقه وانما قال ان
الضبابات الحديثه التي تزود به اوكرانيا
سوف تجعل لروسيا يعني تتحرك بمزيد من
الحزم واستخدام مختلف في الوسائل للدفاع
عنها للدفاع عن ما تسميه موسكو بخطر وجوه
لروسيا ولكن الناطقه لساني كليمن قال انه
الحديث يدور فقط عن ربما توسيع حجم
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكر
حجم العمليه العسكريه هل اليوم يعني
استحضار هذه الواقعه التاريخيه والعوده
الى زمن الحرب العالميه الثانيه هل هو لشد
العصب بسبب يعني ما يحصل على الارض والخوف
من الاخفاقات خصوصا بعد اخفاقات الماضيه
مع سنويات الحرب
لا شك كان روسيا استفادت من تلك العبر
التي منيت بها في العام الماضي وهي بزاويه
الحال الان تصحح ما تم يعني حيث تم ارتكاب
عدد من الاخطاء فيما يتعلق ببعض التراجعات
التي حدثت في الخريف لا شيء في الخريف
الماضي هو يبدو ان روسيا الان بالفعل بصدد
الاعداد لشن هجوم جديد ربما اوسع نطاقا
وفي مختلف شبهات القتال في اوكرانيا لكن
هناك ايضا اقاويل بانه اوكرانيا هي الاخرى
تعد العوده لشني هذا الهجوم بحلول الربيع
بالتالي نحن امام الشين واهتمالات بالغه
الخطوره في المستقبل شكرا لك استاذ يفقيني
حدثنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
في الداخل الاوكراني معركه عسكريه ضد عدو
من الخارج واخرى ضد عدو داخليه متمثل
بالفساد تخوضها اوكرانيا الان حيث عاد ملف
الفساد ليطفوا من جديد بعدما نفذت السلطات
الاوكرانيه اليوم سلسله مداهمات وعمليات
امنيه لمكافحه الفساد اطلق عليها معركه ضد
العدو الداخلي اطلقتها بالتوازي مع اقالات
واستقالات سابقه لكبار مسؤولين اوكران
وبحسب المعلومات فان العمليات تستهدفت
مسؤولين كبار في وزاره الدفاع ومكتب
الضرائب الاوكرانيه فيما علقت مهام اداره
الجمارك اضافه لكل من الملياردير
الاوكراني ايغور كولومويسكي ووزير
الداخليه السابق ارسين افاكوس وقالت رئيس
الاجهزه الامنيه وقال رئيس الاجهزه
الامنيه الاوكرانيه انه وفقا لاوامر
الرئيس زيلينسكي فهذه ليست الا مرحله اولى
ولن يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل ستشمل اي شخص
يخون بلاده مهما كان المنصب فيما علق
مسؤولون اوكرانيون على هذه الحمله بانها
ضروريه كي لا تنقطع المساعدات الغربيه
الكلاب سواء كانت عسكريه او ماليه او
اغاثيه
[موسيقى]
لاول مره قنابل ذكيه بعيده المدى في
طريقها الى اوكرانيا كجزء من حزمه
المساعدات الامريكيه والتي سيعلن عنها في
اقرا بوقت وفقه ما كشفته وصلت الامريكيه
السلاح الذكي هذه المره هو عباره عن قنبله
ذات قطر صغير او كما تسمى بجاء الاسد
اطلاقها من الارض وهي قنبله موجهه بدقه
تزن 250 رطلا ومثبته بصاروخ يبلغ مداه 94
ميلا وهو ابعد من اي قنبله قدمتها واشنطن
حتى الان يمكن اطلاق القنبله من قاذفات
صواريخ مثل النظام هي مارس الذي قدمته
واشنطن في وقت سابق القنبله مجهزه ايضا
باجنحه تسمح لها بالانزلاق نحو اهدافها
بدقه عاليه ومحرك صاروخي لمنحها قوه
اضافيه كما تحتوي ايضا طبعا على انظمه
تتبع متقدمه تم تطوير القنبله الذكيه على
مدار السنوات الماضيه من قبل شركه بوين
بالشراكه مع كوسا اي بي السويديه اما
تصنيعها فهو في المتحده ومنذ بدايه الحرب
مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا ترددت واشنطن
بتزويدها باسلحه بعيده المدى بسبب مخاوف
من الاكياف قد تستخدم هذه الاسلحه لضرب
اهداف داخل الروسي مما يؤدي طبعا الى صدام
مباشر بين كل من موسكو والغرب لكن هذه
القنبله ربما قد تغير من تلك السياسه
والتردد الامريكيه
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل بالملف الاوكراني
ساشير الى ان مجلس النواب الامريكي يعزل
النائبه الديمقراطيه الهام عمر من لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه بالعوده الى الملف
الاوكراني وبينما يستمر الغرب في ارسال
الاسلحه الكلاب يحتاج مخزون اسلحه الناتو
الى تجديد عاجل والحرف في اوكرانيا اظهرت
ان الجيوش الغربيه غير مجهزه للحرب تقول
هنا صحيفه
ان الحرب هي بمثابه جرس انذار لنهضه
الجيوش الغربيه لانه بعد ثلاثه عقود من
سقوط جدار برين اكتشف الغرب بانهم غير
مهيئين لصراع كبير وطويل الامد بعدما
تحولت الحرب في اوكرانيا الى صراع استنزاف
لكافه الاطراف لان الدائمه لامدادها
بالاسلحه ينظر بالخطر ويفوق قدره الناتو
على سبيل المثال اطلق الجيش الاوكراني ما
يقدر بنحو سبعه الاف قذيفه في اليوم
الواحد وهو ما يعادل عمليا اسبوعين من
الانتاج الامريكي للاسلحه وتحول المستمر
الى مدفعيه الناتو لن يؤدي الا الى زياده
على الموردين الغربيين لان صناعه الاسلحه
في اوروبا مجزئه ومخفضه
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا وعلى الارض اعلنت القوات الروسيه
سيطرتها على مدينه فازليفكا شماليه ضخمه
حيث دارت معارك عنيفه هناك لاشهر واضافت
دفاع الروسيه في بيانها اليومي ان قواتها
دمرت مستودعي ذخيره للجيش الاوكراني في
خرسون ياتي هذا فيما اقرت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بصعوبه الوضع في جبهه الشرقيه
فيما كشفت تقارير ان اوكرانيا تتاهب لهجوم
روسي كبير محتمل في غضون ايام مما يعتبره
المحللون اكبر هجوم منذ بدايه
هنا جرت احدى اهم معارك الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وفي المكان ذاته روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه
الالمان وتستعرض قوتها العسكريه
العرض العسكري يوازيه حشد روسي شرقي
اوكرانيا تاهبا لشن اكبر هجوم منذ بدء
الحرب حيث تم حشد نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ
هذا الهجوم او وفق وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي توقع ان يبدا الهجوم تزامنا مع
الذكرى الاولى للحرب المخاوف الاوكرانيه
من حمله جديده
رافقها
بضغط روسي يستهدف الشرق في ليمان وبخمود
بخموت المحاصره بشرق اوكرانيا يتركز
القتال حولها بعد اكثر من عشره شهور من
المعارك الداميه التي استنزفت الطرفين اما
في منطقه دومباس فتكثف روسيا حجم قواتها
بشكل كبير سعيا للسيطره عليها وتستعد
موسكو لفتح جبهه جديده حيث تسعى الى ان
تتقدم قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي فلتت من قبضتها في سوم اوخر
كيف
حشد مئات الالاف من القوات واستهداف عشرات
الاماكن يوميا استراتيجيه القوات الروسيه
بينما تقديرات المخابرات الاوكرانيه تشير
الى ان روسيا نشرت ما يقرب من 300 وعشرين
الف جندي مؤخرا اوكرانيا التي تنتظر
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه
الاخرى من الغرب تكافح للاحتفاظ بارضها
على امتداد
2025 كيلومترا في الشرق
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
التحقيق بمقتل المعارض لحزب الله لقمان
سليم انتهاكا للحق في الحياه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف مسؤول العلاقات
العامه بالحزب الديمقراطي الكردستانيه
المعارض انا اشخاصا من داخل ايران على
اتصال بحزبه ويقدمون معلومات بشان كافه
المجالات
في كافه المجالات
عندهم اتصالات معنا ومع التنظيماتنا في
داخل البلد
كما اشار مسؤوله علاقات العامه في الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
الى ان نوعيه المعلومات التي تصل الحزب
تتعلق بالانتشار العسكري للقوات الايرانيه
على الحدود وحركه عملاء الاستخبارات
الايرانيه التي تخطط لتنفيذ عمليات اغتيال
ضد المعارضين والناشطين السياسيين
نوعيه المعلومات اللزام الايراني في مناطق
الحدوديه تواجد العملاء المخابرات
الايرانيه على مدن الكردستان وحتى بالمرات
الى اقليم القدسات لغرز الاغتيال
المنازلين
للمعلوماتكم من
سنوات
92-93 حتى 95
استشهدوا واخذلوا اكثر من 400 من مقاتلين
الاحزاب الكليه في اقليم الكردسان بيد
العملاء النظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
للمزيد يضم الينا من الرياض عبر تيم صالح
حميد الباحث في الشان الايراني استاذ صالح
برايك يعني ما الفائده اليوم من الكشف عن
هكذا معلومات بان لديهم مصادر داخل
الاجهزه العسكريه هل هي رساله لجهات اخرى
جهات دوليه ام انها رساله انها تخدم
الواقع الكردي
هو في الحقيقه يعني تاثير هذه الاحزاب على
مستوى تنظيم حراك شارع كان مشهودا خاصه
خلال هذه الاربعه اشهر من الانتفاضه
الاخيره حيث دعت هذه الاحزاب عده مرات الى
اضرابات عامه
واستجاب لها الناس في الواقع
حتى قبل هذه الاحتجاجات ايضا كانت هناك
يعني العديد من الدعوات لهذه الاحزاب
لخروج الناس الى الشوارع واستجابه لها هذا
يعني ان شارع الكردي في ايران منظم هناك
حراك يعني يمكن التعويل عليه هناك احزاب
سياسيه ترفع خطابا
تقدميا ديمقراطيا يتناقض مع ما
يمارسه النظام من قمع وبطش وتجهيل وخاصه
ضد النساء وكما نعلم ان شراره هذه
الانتفاضه الاخيره انط من كردستان من
مدينه سقفز مسقط راس مهسى اميني وبالتاكيد
هذه الاحزاب الاحزاب القوميات بشكل عام
وعلى راسها الاحزاب الكرديه يمكن ان تلعب
دورا كبيرا في اي تغيير مستقبلي في ايران
واي قوى سياسيه ايرانيه تريد ان تحدث
غيرها في الداخل لا يمكنها القيام باي شيء
دون مشاركه هذه الاحزاب والممثلين عن
القوى القوميات الرئيسيه
ام هذا الدافع القومي يعني الكبير لدى
الاكراد هناك الذي يمكن ان يكون اعلى
بكثير من الدافع الوطني هذا ما يخيف طبعا
النظام في طهران ولكن العمليات التي يقوم
بها النظام ضد هذه الاحزاب مستمره هل يعني
توغل داخل النظام ممكن ان
يجنبوا عمليات اغتيال لصالح شخصيات كبيره
للاحزاب المعارضه وفي الداخل ايضا
يعني النظام منذ نشاته قبل اربعه عقود وهو
يقوم بقمع هذه الشعوب وخاصه الحركه
الكرديه كما نعلم يعني اول انتفاضتين
قمعتاه عندما استلم الخميني الحكم هما في
كردستان وفي الاهواز عندما طالب هذين
الشعبين بالحكم الذاتي لم تكن هناك اي
دعوات انفصاليه هذه الاحزاب شاركت بقوه في
الاطاحه بالنظام الشاه لكن
البديل كان اسوا ولا تزال قضيه القوميات
الاكراد والعرب
وغيرهم على حالها بل ازدادت ممارسات
النظام سوءا هناك نوعين من الاضطهاد
الاضطهاد في ايران يعاني منه كافه المجتمع
الايراني بكافه شعوبه وقومياته وطوائفه
وهناك اضطهاد مزدوج ضد القومات هذا هو ما
يدفع بهذه الشعوب ان يكون لها حراك اكبر
ونشهد ايضا القمع اكبر يعني اذا لاحظتم
عدد القتلى هي الاكثر في كردستان
وبلوجستان الاعدامات هي اكثر بالنسبه
للنقاء السياسيين الاكراد والبلوش والعرب
ايضا الاهواز لذلك النظام يحاول ان يشوه
على هذا الحراك اولا من خلال ربطه بعوامل
خارجيه ايضا يعسكر
الحراك السلمي الشعبي من خلال استهداف
مقرات هذه الاحزاب التي منذ عقود عملها لا
يختصر الا على العمل السياسي فقط
والاعلامي ولم على عمل ثوره حقيقي شكرا لك
استاذ صالح حميد البحث في شان الايراني
حدثنا من الرياض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في ايران ايضا وتحت نوع من القمع يشبه
الاحتلال العسكري تعيش محافظه بلوشستان في
ايران احد اكبر مراكز الاحتجاجات في
البلاد في الوقت الراهن وفق مركز حقوق
الانسان في ايران هنا في زاهدان عاصمه
محافظه بلوتشستان كما نشاهد لم تهدا فيها
التظاهرات منذ اربعه اشهر رغم القمع
والترهيب المتعدد الاشكال الذي تمارسه
السلطات الايرانيه منذ فتره الاعتقالات
الجماعيه سما اساسيه في حمله الحكومه
القمعيه حيث قدرت وكاله انباء نشطاء حقوق
الانسان اعتقال نحو 20 الف شخص في جميع
انحاء البلاد منذ بدء الاضطرابات اما في
زهدان فتم اعتقال ملايقل عن
185 شخصا ومن المحتمل ان يكون العدد
الفعلي للمعتقلين اعلى بكثير بسبب طبعا
انقطاع الانترنت وتهديدات الاجهزه الامنيه
للعائلات هناك ولكن الامر لم يرهب سكان
زاهدا لبل كان له تاثير معاكس واصر على
الاستمرار بالمطالبه بحقوقهم واسقاط
النظام الايراني مركز حقوق الانسان في
ايران كشف ايضا ان المتظاهرين يتعرضون
لاصابات يفضلون الذهاب ولا يفضلون طبعا
الذهاب الى المستشفىات حتى لو اصابتهم
رصاصه كي يتجنبوا الاعتقال من قبل قوات
النظام
[موسيقى]
اضرب المخرج الايراني جعفر بنهايه عن
الطعام احتجاجا على استمرار اعتقاله منذ
صيف الماضي مع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي
تشهدها ايران واصدر ابنهاي الذي لاقت
افلامه اعجاب النقاد وفاسد بالعديد من
الجوائز الدوليه اصدر بيانا قال فيه انه
سيرفض تناول الطعام او الدواء احتجاجا على
السلوك غير القانوني وغير الانسانيه
للجهاز القضائي والامنيه الايراني وفق
قوله ويعتبر من بين عده فنانين ورياضيين
ومشاهير ايرانيين اعتقلوا على خلفيات
انتقاد النظام الايراني بشكل علني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عربه خبراء حقوقيون في الامم المتحده عن
قلقهم العميق من بطء التحقيق في مقتل
الكاتب والناشط اللبناني المعارض لحزب
الله لقمان سليم قبل عامين جنوبي لبنان
كما طالب الحقوقيون السلطات اللبنانيه
بضمان محاسبه قتلت لقمان محذرين من سياسه
الافلات من العقاب على المجتمع المدني
وقال الخبراء الاربعه الامميون انه من
واجب السلطات اللبنانيه اجراء تحقيق كامل
وضمان محاسبه مرتكبي الجريمه معتبرين ان
عدم اجراء تحقيق سريع وفعال قد يشكل في حد
ذاته انتهاكا للحق في الحياه وكان جثه
الناشط اللبناني لقمان سليم قد عثر عليها
في سيارته مصابه باعير ناريه في النبطيه
جنوب لبنان وتعتبر معقل حزب الله المدعوم
من ايران والذي كان سليم ينتقده بشده
[موسيقى]
اكد الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد انا
بلاده حريصه على تعزيز التعاون مع
السعوديه على مختلف الاصعده وخلال
استقباله وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان شدد رشيد على ان العراق
يواصل التنسيق مع السعوديه بشان عدد من
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
هذا والتقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه رئيس
مجلس النواب العراقي محمد الحلبوسي في
العاصمه بغداد وجرا خلال اللقاء استعراض
العلاقات بين البلدين في العديد من
المجالات وتعزيز البرلماني كما بحث
الطرفان ايضا التطورات الاقليميه والدوليه
ندعم كل جهود الحكومه العراقيه في سبيل
تعزيز الرخاء
والاستقرار في العراق
والسعي الى تحقيق
الاستدامه في النمو والازدهار للعراق وسوف
نعمل سويا لدعم هذا والتعاون في هذا
المجال بالذات من خلال تفعيل مجلس التنسيق
المشترك والذي يعمل على تفعيل مشاريع
عديده وفرص كثيره وهناك مجال واسع للتنسيق
والتعاون بين القطاعين الخاصين بالذات في
بلدينا
لتعظيم الاستفاده من الفرص المتاحه
في العراق ايضا لكن في الشان الداخلي فبعد
ضربه انخفاض العمله العراقيه امام الدولار
ضربه اخرى في صميم الاقتصاد العراقي حيث
تداول عراقيون تحذيرات من انتشار عمله
مزيفه من فئه 25 الف دينار في السوق
انتشارا واسعا فلنتابعه كميه ضخمه من
المزور موجوده بالسوق
الدينار العراقي لا ثقه فيه عراقيون
يشككون في الاموال منه المزور بدقه عاليه
والاخر سهل الكشف فئه الخمسه والعشرين الف
دينار منتشره في السوق مزوره ومتداوله
العراقيون الصفاقوا على المحظور تحذيرات
من فخ التزوير وغيرها فيديوهات تعليميه
لكشف التزوير النجمه شايفين
يطلع عندك كلمه العراق اذا طلعت كلمه
العراق هاي تعتبر مو مزوره
ذهول في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الدينار
بين التزييف وتخفيض قيمته امام الدولار
واتهامات لايران بتورطها في ذلك عبر
اذرعها في العراق
الاطار هرب الدولار هاشتاج وجد فيه
عراقيون مساحه للتعبير عن السخط والسخريه
مستشار الحكومه العراقيه نفى للعربيه ما
هو متداول عن تزييف العمله مشككا في صحه
الاخبار فيما اكد ان ما يدوره هو محاولات
فقط لافتعال الازمات واثاره الشارع
العراقي غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي التزام بلاده
تجاه الفلبين بموجه بمعاهده الدفاع
المشترك وعلى دعم الولايات المتحده في
حاله وقوع هجمات وشدد في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
مع نظيره الفلبيني على التزامه واشنطن
بتعزيز القدرات المتبادله بين البلدين
لمقاومه الهجوم المسلح
ناقشنا الاجراءات الملموسه لمعالجه
الانشطه المزعزعه للاستقرار في المياه
المحيطه بالفلبين بما في ذلك بحر الفلبين
الغربي وسنبقى ملتزمين بتعزيز قدراتنا
المتبادله لمقاومه الهجوم المسلحه هذا
مجرد جزء من جهودنا لتحديث تحالفنا وهي
ايضا مهمه بشكل خاص لان الصين تواصل تقديم
مطالباتها غير المشروعه في بحر الفلبين
الغربي
طلبت رئيسه الوزراء الفنلندي
بتصديق على طلبات بلادها للانضمام للنت
وفي اقرب وقت ممكن مؤكده انضمام بلادها
لدول الحلف الناتو من مصلحه الجميع واوضحت
ايضا ان بلادها تطمح لاكمال عمليات
الانضمام معربه عن كوريا للاوضاع الراهنه
التي تقدم السويد كطفل شقي على حد وصفها
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد قرار الفيدرالي الامريكيه بنوك عربيه
تحدثها برفع اسعار الفائده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رغم قرار رفع الاحتياطيه
الفيدراليه الامريكيه امس اسعار الفائده
ربع نقطه مئويه تتامل اسواق العالميه وفقا
لخبراء تخفيف الضغط عليها واستمرار موجه
الارتدادات التي شهدتها الاسبوع الماضي
فيما اوضح رئيس الاحتياطيه الفيدرالي بان
الاقتصاد الامريكي يحقق نموا متواضعا
ومكاسب قويه في الوظائف مشيرا الى انه يرى
طريقا للعوده الى مستوى التضخم المستهدف
عند اثنين بالمئه دون حدوث انكماش اقتصادي
كبير او زياده في معدلات البطاله
عقب قرار الفيدرالي لحقت البنوك المركزيه
في السعوديه والامارات والبحرين وسلطنه
عمان بخطوه الفيدراليه برفع اسعار الفائده
فيما ابقى المركزيه القطريه على سعر
الفائده دون تغيير
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو وليد
الحلو رئيس قسم ابحاث السوق والتدريب في
امانه كابيتال اهلا وسهلا بك الرفع الثامن
من السنه الماضيه حتى هذه السنه الرفع
الثاني اللي هو بمعدل اقل من الرفعات
الماضيه هذه النسب هل ممكن هل حققت
النتيجه المرجوه بتخفيض التضخم في
الولايات المتحده وكيف انعكست على اقتصاد
المنطقه يمكن هو على حسب تصريحات محافظ
الفيدرالي امريكي امبارح ان عمليه تخفيض
التضخم ابتدت يمكن نظريا عندنا ده الشهر
الرابع من تراجع معدلات التضخم اللي
موجوده عندنا ولكن على حسب كلام الفيدرالي
الامريكي مازال امامنا المزيد من الوقت
الوقت واهم مرحله هي الاستمرار على
الفوائد المرتفعه خلال الفتره القادمه
يعني هذا الرفع ياتي للمره الاولى في
العام 2023 الاقتصاد العالمي كله يعاني من
معدلات تضخم عاليه حتى يعني من تسريح
العديد من الشركات الامريكيه وارتفاع نسب
البطاله هذا الرفع على المنطقه كيف يؤثر
على القروض على المواطنين وخصوصا ان
القدره الشرائيه تاكلت ايضا بعديد من
الدول بالضبط يمكن دي نقطه جدا مهمه ان
احنا بنركز دلوقتي على التاثيرات اللي
موجوده التاثير الرئيسي اللي موجود مش
بيوصل للناس بنفس الطريقه يعني اذا ما
كنتش شخص بالنسبه للتاثير المباشر ما كنتش
شخص مقبل ان انت تاخد قرض او تمويل عقاري
او كل هذه الامور او حتى عندك بس المرجش
على او سابت ثابت النسبه بصوره كبيره انت
مش حاسس بالتشديد الاثر الغير مباشر هو من
الاشخاص اللي بيكونوا شغالين في شركات
مقبله على مثل هذه الامور او مثلا زي ما
احنا واضح عندنا بعد ارتفاع المورج عندنا
مثلا
النشاط العقاري في بعض التراجع الموجود
فده ممكن ياثر على شركتك ويؤثر عليك
بالتبعيه فالفكره الرئيسيه ان في عندنا
اثار مباشره مبنيه على لان رفع الفائده في
النهايه هو الحديث عن تكلفه الحصول على
الاموال بصوره كبيره ابقى معي يا استاذ
سعود اليك مشاهدينا ايضا بخبر اقتصادي اخر
خسر الملياردير الهندي جوتام اجاني لقب
اغنى رجل في اسيا بعد انهيار اسهم مجموعه
اداني تابعه له وفقدانها اكثر من 107
مليارات دولار من قيمتها السوقيه بعد
تقرير من شركه استثماريه امريكيه اتهم
المجموعه بالتلاعب والاحتيال المحاسبه
فنتابع التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
اني
وعلى اثر هذه الاخبار انخفضت الثروه
الشخصيه لصاحب المجموعه ما ادى الى خسارته
لقب اغنى رجل في اسيا وفقد غوتام اداني
مايقرب من 75 مليار دولار منذ وصول ثروته
للذروه عندما بلغت 145 مليار دولار في
العام الماضي وادت الخسائر الى هبوط رجل
الاعمال الهندي الى المركز الخامس عشر في
قائمه الاشخاص في العالم علما ان ترتيبه
كان الثالث قبل صدور تقرير هندنبرغ وتمثل
الخسائر انتكاسه حاده لجوتام اداني الذي
هجر التعليم وتحول الى ملياردير مع زياده
قيمه اسهم مجموعته التي تتضمن شركات موانئ
ومطارات وتعدين وطاقه
محمد زهير العربيه
مشددا الى
ولي تاره للمليارات حصلت معه هل هو
التقرير هل فعلا هناك تلاعب كبير اتحدث عن
التلاعب الضريبي التي تتحدث عنه وعن يعني
المضاربات هل هو بهذه القيمه بالضبط يمكن
هي النقطه الرئيسيه ان التقرير كمفصل جدا
ده تقرير من 200 صفحه وصل
للوكالات المختلفه وايضا كان في بعض الناس
بتحاول ان هي تدعمه مثلا زي بالاكمل نتكلم
على هذا الامر وهو واحد من كبار
المستثمرين الموجودين او من المستثمرين
بصوره كبيره ولكن يبدو ان الاسواق مش
بتشتري هذا الامر وخصوصا ان احنا في مناخ
يمكن الطبيعه الاستثماريه فيها خطيره جدا
دلوقتي تمن القرار الاستثماري الخاطئ جدا
مكلف لان انت مش بتخسري بس الخساره من
القرار بتاعك ولكن ايضا بتخسري في معدلات
التضخم اللي هي جدا مرتفعه وبتختار الفرصه
البديله ان الفلوس دي تكون في البنك
وبتجيب لك فايده لغايه دلوقتي اكثر من
اربعه فاصله خمسه وسبعين في الميه فهي دي
هي دي اللي خلى هذا الامر يتسارع بصوره
كبيره هل ممكن ان يكون هناك ما وراء موضوع
الديون او التلاعب الضريبه
او او فقط هذا هو التقرير يعني
لو ما كانش التقرير في جزء كبير من الصحه
ما كانش لي هذا هذا الحجم من التاثير هذه
النقطه المهمه لن
حصل او مصير هذه الشركه برايك بالنسبه
لهذه الشركه اعتقد لان دائما وابدا لما
بتيجي شركه بيكون عليها ضغط جدا كبير
بيكون فيه 2 اوبشنز التخلي عن الشركه
تمامه وبدايه من جديد او محاوله اللي هو
العمل على الشركه عشان تعود مره اخرى في
معظم الاحيان لما الشركه بيكون فيها هذا
الحجم الكبير من من الفساد او من هذا
الحجم الكبير من سوء السمعه فغالبا مثل
هذه الامور لا يتم يعني تصليحها فغالبا
بتبقى في استحوازات بتبقى في مثلا تغيير
الاداره بتاعت الشركه يعني
الموضوع اشبه بما حدث في اف تي اكس في
شركه العملات المشفره او منصه العملات
المشفره بالضبط كان ممكن انقذها على
الاوراق اللي كان في مستثمرين كان ممكن
انقذها ولكن الفكره ايه تكلفه السمعه
السيئه اللي كانت موجوده وهل السمعه دي
ستلتصق للشركه واكيد كانت هتلتصق بها
بصوره واضحه شكرا لك استاذ وليد حلو رئيس
قسم ابحاث السوق والتدريب في امان شكرا
على وجودك معنا شكرا
[موسيقى]
اجلت الحكومه الاسرائيليه او اجلت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تنفيذ امر هدم قريه الخان
الاحمر البدويه واخلاقها من السكان الى
الصيف المقبل متذرعه بقدوم شهر رمضان
الفضيل وعدم رغبتها في توتير الاجواء هذا
وذكرت مصادر اسرائيليه ان الولايات
المتحده تمارس ضغوطا على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لتوقف عن خطوات من شانها
الاضرار برؤيه حلت دولتين التي تتبناها
اداره بايدن
لا غرابه ان تجري هذه الطفله حافيه في هذا
الجو البارد والماطر انه دفء المكان الذي
ولدت فيه رغم انها باتت تدرك وفي هذا
العمر الصغير انه قد يفقد في اي لحظه هذا
ما قاله لنا سكان القريه البدويه الخان
الاحمر ان اطفالهم يوجهون لهم اسئله
مصيريه لا يملكون لها اجابه احنا عجين
لنفهم اطفالنا
احنا عزيلا فهمهم كل ماده سياره ما يشوفوا
راحوا يعني ما انت متريح لا في الليل ولا
في النهار للمره التاسعه تضطر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لتاجيل تنفيذ امر هدم واخلاء
الخان الاحمر الذي اقرته المحكمه
الاسرائيليه
ورغم ان جمعيات استيطانيه وضعت حكومه
نتنياهو في الزاويه قضائيا لتنفيذ الاخلاء
الا ان الضغوط الامريكيه كانت اقوى هذه
المره فهذا التجمع البدوي المبني من بي
صفيح اصبح بقاؤه يعني بقاء خيار حل
الدولتين هنا ممر هنا مركز السلام ليس انه
بيت موجود هنا لانه اذا تم اقتلاء هذه
القريه سيتم هناك بناء مستوطنين قطعه
الضفه الغربيه شمال وجنوب الفريق الامريكي
السياسي والامني الموجود في المنطقه نجح
في اول خطوه نحو التهدئه لكن المهمه تبدو
معقده وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لم يستجب
للضغوط وقرر اقتطاع نحو 30 مليون دولار من
اموال الفلسطينيين فيما يواصل بنجبير
اجراءاته العقابيه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين
في السجون ما يهدد بانفجار ميداني في اي
لحظه
تتوقفهم الاطماع الاستيطانيه وتهديدات
بنجافير من جهه والضغوط الامريكيه
والمساعي الاوروبيه من الجهه الاخرى ورغم
كل هذا الواقع الصعب والمستقبل المجهول
ينجح هؤلاء البدو حتى هذه اللحظه في
البقاء على ارضهم من قريه الخان الاحمر
عبد الحفيظ العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
را
ليا مصرف المركزي البريطاني هذا القرار
يعني عدم وضع صوره ملك تشارلز الثالث على
العمله الورقيه من فئه الخمسه دولارات وان
الاوراق النقديه لن تحمل تدريجيا صوره اي
عاهل بريطاني لكن البنك المركزي لم يذكر
اي تفاصيل بشان صوره الملكه الراحله
اليزابيث التي تظهر على بعض العملات
المعدنيه المتداوله وسيتم استشاره سكان
الاصليون بشان التصميم الجديد الذي سيكرم
ثقافه الاسره الاوائل وتاريخهم وطباعه
الورقه النقديه الجديده
ستستغرق سنوات كما اكد البنك المركزي
[موسيقى]
تلوث الهواء يتسبب بالقلب والاكتئاب
للانسان وفق ما كشفته دراسه جديده بعد
تتبع حوالي نصف مليون شخص في المملكه
المتحده لمده 11 عاما فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
بعد زياره وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الى
الخرطوم السودان يعلن الاتفاق مع اسرائيل
على تطبيع العلاقات
بامجاد انتصارات
الالمانيه من على حدود بلاده
في كافه المجالات
في داخل البلد
قضيه انهيار مجموعه اداني تتفاعل والمخاوف
تلاحق المستثمرين فيها
الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا
شكرا لحسن المتابعه لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره والان الى 360 مع زميله راويه اهلا
بك
السودان على طريق التطبيع مع اسرائيل
ونتنياهو في باريس تابعينا تفضل